what you're looking at here is
definitive evidence of lost ancient high
technology known as the colossi of
memnon these two statues are located in
Luxor Egypt however each of them were
carved out of one solid piece of
quartzite stone which originally weighed
approximately 1,000 tons apiece
however being cut and carved they are
estimated at 720 tons apiece now the
fact they're made out of quartzite is
unbelievable because that is a seven out
of ten on the Mohs scale of hardness
with a diamond being a ten
now most megalithic structures around
Egypt and elsewhere around the world are
carved out of granite or basalt which
basalt is approximately a six out of ten
on the Mohs scale and granite varies
between six six and a half depending on
the type of granite now how they were
able to cut and carve this stone is a
complete mystery
after all modern-day Egypt ologist claim
that the dynastic Egyptians utilized
stone hammers and bronze chisels to cut
and carve stone however that's
completely impossible with this type of
stone as well as grin and basalt as well
however many people have proposed
different methods that could have been
utilized a low very primitive to cut and
carve different types of stone in the
megalithic structures as being commonly
around Egypt including the pyramids
however I'm yet to see any of these
methods done on quartzite now that's not
to say it's not possible however the
size of these statues is astounding and
to think that they would have used those
primitive type methods on something this
large I consider to be incredibly
unlikely now what's interesting about
these two stone statues being made at a
quartzite is that the closest area in
the region they could have came from is
more than 420 miles away nearly 700
kilometers in modern day Cairo where
there is a quarry that was known and
proven to be utilized by the dynastic
Egyptians for various statues and other
stone structures so the question becomes
how on earth were they able to move
something so massive now if they were
moved before they were cutting carved
like I said a thousand tons of piece as
they stand now 720 tonnes and you only
have to look at what it took in 2012 for
Los Angeles County Museum of the Arts to
move a 340 ton stone they had to custom
build a 295 foot long 196 wheel Emerton
national truck to move something that
was half the weight of these statues and
almost a third of the weight of what
these stones would have been prior to
being cut and carved many Egyptologists
theorized the different stone blocks for
example utilizing the construction of
the pyramids would have been moved over
tree trunks however that is completely
unrealistic when you consider something
this big and massive over that far of a
distance in fact if you research the
colossi of memnon you'll see that
there's virtually zero explanation into
how these were cut and carved now so
many people at a first glance besides
the fact that these are incredibly huge
they're obviously incredibly damaged
however upon a closer inspection you can
see that there's incredible high
precision that was utilized in various
areas of these statues prior to being
destroyed now whether they were
destroyed by people after some sort of
war who knows but there is evidence that
has been discovered by professional
geologists that they have been tea
blasted in some way and some theorized
that they may have been subjected to a
plasma blast from the Sun tens of
thousands of years ago which further
validate the theory that the dynastic
Egyptians did not create these statues
and that they found them and that the
human civilization that existed before
the great Cataclysm that it happened
twelve thousand nine hundred and eighty
years ago would have had some sort of
advanced high technology and even look
at this photo here where you can see
that the base although taller than most
people most of that base is still buried
under the ground the base themselves
though however are more than four
hundred tons of piece look guys what we
were taught in school and what they were
actively teaching in school today and in
the textbooks is clearly inaccurate and
that there's so many holes in the
theories that modern-day Egyptologists
have that it's completely impossible for
these statues and many other examples of
megalithic structures around Egypt and
elsewhere around the world to have been
done by the primitive methods that have
been stated and proposed by modern day
Egyptologists definitely check out my
video about the ancient Cataclysm as
there's definitive evidence that there
was a massive
hasser fee on planet earth that reset
human civilization nearly 13,000 years
ago anyways guys I'm Jimmy this is
bright insight like and subscribe
helping spread the message take care
everybody